pas être un grand succès d'abord parce
qu'ils sont organisées un peu partout il
ya beaucoup de gens qui veulent y
participer
parce que les français aussi trouve que
c'est une excellente idée regardez ce
sondage opinionway qui a été réalisé
pour le figaro lci rtl les plus des deux
tiers des français 67% pour être précis
trouve que c'est une bonne chose
c'est un gadget alexander vecchio ce
grand débat où il peut ça peut vraiment
permettre de sortir de cette crise
démocratique quand même dans laquelle on
est plongé
non je pense qu'on saura si c'est
vraiment un succès à terme si des choses
ceux des enseignements sont concrets
sont tirées de ce débat donc je pense
qu'il est trop tôt pour pour juger genre
est prévu que j'aurais préféré à des
référendums d'initiative populaire
je le dis que les très clairement voir
une dissolution
mais c'est le choix qui a été fait par
le président de la république maintenant
c'est fait je crois que il serait utile
notamment pour l'opposition de
participer à ces débats de faire la nrj
un certain nombre de propositions
d'idées est justement de confronter le
président de la république s'il y avait
vraiment des propositions fortes qui
sort de ce débat il va être obligé d'y
répondre sinon ça mais montrera bien que
c'était un enfumage depuis le début
canadian vous parliez des deux des
grands principes
philosophique y sommes inquiets la
démocratie représentative
c'est emmanuel macron qui a été élu ce
sont les députés qui le soutiennent donc
est ce que c'est vraiment légitime de
dire au peuple
allez-y donnez nous votre avis on en
fera peut-être des lois vous avez tout à
fait raison sur un point c'est que le
besoin même d'organiser ce grand débat
est un camouflet pour les institutions
c'est à dire que le grand débat national
on est quand même censé l'avoir eue lors
de la période électorale qui aboutit
donc à l'édition des manuels macron moi
j'ai appris à l'école que le parlement
c'était le représentant de la volonté
générale de la beauté nationale or en
organisant ce grand débat finalement
emmanuel macron acte le fait que tous
les canaux institutionnels classiques
sont aujourd'hui des légitimes et que
les français ne s'identifie plus à leur
classe politique alors à aux
parlementaires aux leaders syndicaux
cause intermédiaire donc deux conduits
là c'est vrai que l'organisation même de
ceux de ce grand débat pose problème
pour tout cas la réputation des
institutions françaises s'y attend là
qu'il faut savoir si ce débat va être un
succès moi je suis très sceptique je
pense vraiment que rien de politiquement
exploitables pourra sortir de ce débat
parce que on se berce dont cette
illusion un peu jacobine qui aurait en
france une uniformité des intérêts des
préférences alors qu'on l'a vu avec les
gilets jaunes et préoccupations sociales
individuelles sont complètement atomisé
et que un référendum
l'institutionnalisation du référendum ne
va pas gommer le fait que la société
française reste très éclatée sur un
trade sur un tas de sujets voilà la
seule cible et de la solution c'est pas
une solution miracle mais la seule la
solution la plus efficace pour répondre
à la diversité à l'atomisation de la
demande politique serait d'amorcer une
véritable décentralisation suis pas du
tout convaincu qu'un grand débat
national permettra de trouver de
retrouver cette volonté générale qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas encore une fois
qu'on te regarde et à l'opinion publique
sur un tas de questions en particulier
sur ce plateau vous aviez mis un gilet
jaune en soutien au mouvement est ce que
vous leur mettrais aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous vous sentez toujours gilet
jaune le fond la revendication
demeure légitime pour moi ça ne change
pas le ras-le-bol fiscale l'excès de
pression fiscale je pense que c'est un
con ce qu'ils ont dit trans partisan
maintenant c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup
plus de mal si vous voulez à m'afficher
avec parce que compte tenu des
débordements des dérives et et de tout
ce qui se passe dans la rue c'est
beaucoup plus difficile aujourd'hui de
s'identifier comme étant un partisan du
mouvement des gilet jaune ne s'était pas
un mouvement initié homogène et que mais
je partage toujours le fond des
revendications et je pense que la la
l'exaspération est légitime ça ça change
pas sur twitter on vous a posé la
question le succès du grand débat
peut-il être perçu comme une revanche
des invisibles sous ces gens qui
s'abstiennent aux élections tous ces
gens qu'on n'entend pas habituellement
sur les plateaux de télévision ou dans
les studios de radio et vous êtes 72 % à
considérer que non donc vraiment un
regard assez critique
c'est évidemment pas un sondage puisque
ce sont vous chers internautes qui
donnait votre votre avis
[Musique]
reiter car nous disent ce n'est pas le
débat le problème c'est ce que macron va
en faire et babineau ajoute si c'était
un grand débat marlène schiappa n'aura
pas besoin d'en faire la promotion chez
cyril hanouna parce que vous savez que
la secrétaire d'état à l'égalité homme
femme va organiser un débat avec
l'animateur de télévision
cyril hanouna maxis bay qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est bien cette
démocratie de la base
oui c'est très bien ce grand débat moi
je trouve que c'est un rare moment on
peut tous se posent et mettre tout sur
la table s'écouter alors le premier
enfant c'est qu'on débat beaucoup mais
moi je trouve qu'on débat pas assez en
profondeur c'est à dire que on débat
souvent dans un espèce de manichéisme
binaire de dire c'est l'élite contre le
peuple les mondialistes contre les
nationalistes les riches contre les
pauvres
et moi j'ai un manque dans ce débat il
ya un peu plus de nuances c'est à dire
qu'on rentre vraiment dans les sujets et
de ce que je vois c'est que pour
l'instant c'est un succès il ya beaucoup
de remonter les journaux le dise on voit
des au niveau local d organisation c'est
ya un kit sont mis à disposition pour le
faire
donc les gens s'emparent de ce débat
donc ça il faut le reconnaître je vois
aussi des sujets qui étaient jamais
abordé avant c'est à dire par exemple
l'impôt sur le revenu progressivité
proportionnalité vous avez vous même
publié une superbe enquête sur les hauts
fonctionnaires
le revenu des hauts fonctionnaires
certains qui gagnent plus que le
président la république et premiers
ministres mais c'est des choses qu'on
n'est pas trop l'habitude d'entendre
comme ça donc ça me des sujets comme ça
sur le sur le devant de la scène qui
font du bien moi j'espère juste que ce
débat on pourra discuter tout c'est à
dire que pour qu'un débat soit vrai soit
juste il faut que la liberté
d'expression soit totale et j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir parler de tous les
sujets et en tout cas moi je vous dis
que génération libre va prendre toute sa
place dans ce débat là et qu'on va au
cours des prochaines semaines contribué
aussi à notre manière au débat national
alors cette contribution elle est très
diverses le figaro magazine aussi se
lancer dans l'aventuré vous l'avez vu
avec la bande annonce juste avant
l'émission
le week-end dernier on a proposé à nos
lecteurs de réagir sur les sujets du
grand débat et pas seulement d'autres
qu'on avait rajouté alors il ya deux
enseignements
le premier c'est que il ya un vrai une
vraie envie de donner un point de vue on
est à plus de 500 réponses en quelques
jours seulement et puis deux
préoccupations qui reviennent en nombre
chez nos lecteurs un la nécessité d'une
baisse de la fiscalité est celle d'un
meilleur contrôle de l'immigration avec
beaucoup de mails favorable à
l'instauration de quotas vous savez que
c'était l'une des propositions avancées
par le président de la république dans
sa lettre aux français ce débat il est
toujours en cours donc vous pouvez
apporter votre contribution à l'adresse
mail suivante débat fig mag at
lefigaro.fr
jean mathieu pernin cc c'est une façon
pour les gens qui n'ont jamais la parole
de l'apprendre ce débat et ce alors moi
je trouve que ce débat national ça fait
un peu fantasme de thérapeutes sur
grande échelle parce que là on a
l'impression que ça y est on dit tout
essayer tout va se régler
alors après c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne chose parce que pendant qu'en une
présidentielle moi je me suis je me
souviens avoir fait beaucoup de sujets
dessus souvenez vous avant qu'emmanuel
macron se déclarent y avait beaucoup de
mouvement citoyen qui disait nous on
veut un candidat citoyens on veut
discuter davantage en fait on veut des
respiration démocratique et ça c'est un
thème qui revenue souvent qu'entre les
élections que les français n'auraient
pas assez la parole
alors est ce que en effet ça doit
s'adapter sur des nouvelles formes comme
des référendum d'initiative locale le
seul problème c'est qu'on a vu notre
dame des landes
ça a été fait et puis l'état s'est assis
dessus nationale avons mené à rien et
indivisible locale
alors ça prend des gars ça et après
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tout dépend
de ce qui va en sortir mais il est vrai
que le cadre moi je trouve fixé par
emmanuel macron c'est bien de fixer un
cadre mais il suffit d'aller dans les
débats et de voir que ça déborde
largement en fait dire qu'il faut faire
attention à ne pas prendre seul intérêt
particulier pour l'intérêt général aussi
mais tant qu'on a entendu que nous parce
que ça déborde
le rôle d'un débat ce n'est pas juste
justement encadré dans des barbelés à 10
ans on parle que de ça parce qu'il ya
des choses qui n'intéressent qu'une
personne
oui bah et que tout le monde mais ses
soucis en fait je pense que c'est en
faisant ça aussi que cette personne peut
réaliser et que les autres peuvent lui
fera pas sa résolution adoptée derrière
mais c'est un peu probable et au moins
ils auront l'occasion dû voyage déjà
fait un vrai rita dire que l'engouement
pour ce grand débat c'est une arme aussi
à double tranchant c'est à dire que si
in fine et les gens se réalisent que
leur voix et demeure diluée dans le
processus électoral ça manquerait encore
beaucoup plus de frustration est donc là
on aura épuisé tous les gadgets pour
acheter la paix sociale et bon courage
pour la suite
ce qui est intéressant aussi dans le
débat du figaro il ya la question
européenne
je note qu'elle est absente de ce débat
là alors bien sûr y aura une élection
européenne par la suite mais il paraît
très très difficile de discuter toutes
ces questions sont discutées de l'europe
puisque effectivement ce qui les
décisions qui sont prises au en europe
ont une influence très grande sur sur la
politique française donc je pense que ça
fait partie de l'hypocrisie peut-être de
ce débat j'espère me tromper encore une
fois attendons les résultats concrets
mais cette absence est quand même
extrêmement préjudiciable puisque vous
le disiez 7
ce grand débat intervient juste avant
les élections européennes qui sont en
mai prochain
certains disent même que emmanuel macron
est entré dans la campagne européenne à
travers ce débat et que donc
toutes ces interventions devraient être
décompté du temps de parole de la
république en marche ça vous paraît ça
vous paraît légitime sais pas mais c'est
vrai que là on assiste même à d le
problème c'est que je puisse vous avez
vu quand même il ya eu six heures le
premier départ quand même quand on va
diffusés par les chaînes défendant l'onu
il ya un moment bon fallait en fait il
fallait vraiment vraiment super enfin
supporter de regarder pendant six heures
ça et il ya eu un petit souci cgirsa
fait pas un programme de télévision mais
ça répond aussi à une certaine
revendications des jeunes par rapport
aux journalistes en disant à cause de
votre montage va maintenant vous fait
défaut sujet donc nous ce qu'on veut
c'est que du direct en permanence donc
là à partir de là c'est plus tellement
du journalisme non mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le président de la
république ça devait être un débat entre
les français
là le président de la république et
l'animateur du débat
il structure il répond enfin c'est quand
même un rôle extrêmement curieux qui est
sa triple but est effectivement deuxième
partie relation c'est qu'en fait ces six
heures là ils débattent des mères c'est
à dire qu'en fait dire on vient au
niveau local et là je rejoins fergal
rapidement sur son sort ce que tu disais
c'est que on a besoin d'une
décentralisation et finalement emmanuel
macron acte la décentralisation en
allant mener ce débat auprès des maires
qui sont eux les plus proches des
préoccupations des français
et ça serait bien qu'il me fasse pas que
aller auprès des maires mais qu' il
donne il redonne du pouvoir ils rendent
du pouvoir je rappelle que les gilets
jaunes ils disent
rendez l'argent rendait le pouvoir et le
rendait le pouvoir il est très très
important
donc c'est peut-être justement en
redonnant la confiance et la
responsabilité au niveau local qu'on
peut retrouver peut-être un moyen de
vivre ensemble est d'arriver à des
conclusions communes le fait qu'il aille
voir les mères ma vie est révélateur du
fait qu'il a lui-même conscience que les
mères c'est l'une des rares catégories
c'est sûr les rescapés en fait du
discrédit des institutions c'est à dire
que l'on trouvera des sondages d'opinion
c'est l'une des rares figures politiques
encore respectée dans glee tout à fait
donc ses portes et ce manque
vous le faites de marteler que voilà
peut-être qu'une sortie de crise
nécessite de gros de disparation là cela
dit sans vouloir toucher votre votre
enthousiasme pour les mères sont aussi
ceux qui demandent beaucoup plus de
moyens toujours qui se plaignent de la
baisse des dotations pour la baisse de
la dépense publique c'est assez moyen
ce sont aussi des gens qui vont chercher
des subventions les meilleurs qui
justement n'ont pas les moyens de vraies
communisme français en quelque sorte
pour ça qu'ils mendient aussi de
l'argent à l'état aucune autonomie
fiscale en france aux usa les maires
sont obligés d'aller demander à paris ne
peuvent pas lever enfin c'est très très
limité les impôts sur lesquels ils ont
eu un vrai pouvoir un vrai levier
ils doivent aller constamment d'un
peuple à la taxe foncière une partie des
frais ça représente une minorité de tous
que de toutes les dépenses locales et en
fait pour leurs dépenses pour leurs
frais de fonctionnement ils doivent
aller demander en permanence et ça
instaure un espèce de rapport à font-ils
dix ans entre paris et le reste de la
france et qu'il faudrait je pense revoir
mais là au niveau institutionnel au
niveau de l'organisation de l'état après
attention la différence dans les grandes
villes et dans les petites villes c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que là on
voit que les débats s'organisent surtout
dans les petites villes ou dans les
villages ou en campagne
paris lyon marseille c'est pas là où il
ya plus de débat et il ya un moment est
ce qu'il n'ya pas une fracture tu as
coupé entre les villes les plus les plus
peuplées et le reste de la france aussi
c'est là où on voit à paris ce sont des
débats organisés par les députés en
marche souvent et celles offertes
attention aussi par après ça oui mais
c'est en même temps c'est logique
puisque ce mouvement a révélé un clivage
entre deux france après moi exclure les
villes où il ya un million de personnes
2 millions 3 fin voilà vous voyez n'ont
même pas ses salles qui vont bien qu'ils
se sont pas tellement ça va bien mais
moi je suis beaucoup plus sceptique sur
sur la décentralisation je pense qu'on
est un pays extrêmement fracturé que
donner une autonomie fiscale au maire
c'est quand même à à double tranchant ça
peut creuser encore les inégalités
justement entre les grosses villes
riches et les pauvres entre des villes
totalement communautariser
je n'ose imaginer qu'on donne plus
effectivement d'autonomie à certaines
communes de seine-saint-denis que j'ai
bien que j'ai bien que j'ai bien connue
donc moi je suis plutôt pour
et je pense qu'il y avait de ça aussi
dans le mouvement des gilets jaunes pour
un retour de l'état régalien partout sur
le pays il y avait aussi une demande de
de service public une demande de de
considération de l état de régaler 1
comment plus personnes s'identifient à
l'état ont pas de demande d'état
régalien en mai ont vandalisé préfecture
jean ne s'identifie mené parce que
l'état justement et inefficace mais je
pense qu'on paie suffisamment d'impôts
d'accord je pense qu'on paie ce sujet il
ya un état bureaucratique qui est
détesté qui effectivement met en place
les 80 kilomètres heure qui s'occupent
maintenant j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
comité pour vérifier les blagues dans
les sketchs qui est qu'ils soient pas
trop sexy et ça effectivement c'est une
dérive totale de l'état bureaucratique
après il ya des missions que l'état doit
assurer je pense qu'on aura besoin de
l'état si on veut recréer un tissu
d'emplois dans certains dans certains
territoires il ya une véritable
politique d'aménagement du territoire à
mettre en place donc voilà je me méfie
de cette illusion de la délocalisation
par ailleurs ça fait des années qu'on
fait de plus en plus de délocalisations
gpal importe peu l'impression que là se
délocalisera sur lapsus de
décentralisation aussi et j'ai pas
l'impression que ça que ça va mais aussi
depuis les années 80 il ya des médias de
nouvelles lois de décentralisation
quasiment à chacun à chaque législature
et et on voit l'un que fait par meetic
on a beaucoup parlé de la suisse la
suisse est le pays le plus décentralisée
du monde
oui mais c'est d'europe et c'est aussi
une des raisons qui fait que ce pays et
prospérer à l'aise avec ces institutions
dernière question là dessus a votre avis
il ya des propositions qui émerge
massivement ce grand débat est ce que le
président a un public est tenu de les
mettre en oeuvre ou est-ce qui garde son
libre arbitre tenu juridiquement il
l'est pas mais pas politiquement ou
moralement je pense qu'il est et je
pense qu'il est bloqué avec sa est
forcément après va savoir il faut savoir
vraiment ces questions là mais je pense
qu'il y aura quelque chose de l'ordre de
la consultation des citoyens après ça
forcément un référendum alors quand
est-ce qu'ils professent qu'il aura lieu
parce que
mine de rien l'euro rend dans une
période électorale il ya chaque année il
ya des élections donc la cia voire des
municipales et régionales et donc est ce
qu'on peut prendre le risque de perdre
un référendum juste avant une élection
ses soucis en fait et on peut se
demander c'est pour ça qu'on peut se
demander si ce n'était pas aussi une
manière de gagner du temps parce qu'on
voit pas très bien où est ce qu'il va
placer son référendum on peut il pourra
considérer après les européennes que
d'une certaine manière les européennes
ont réglé la question politique après il
ya il ya une solution moi qui me paraît
serait pas intelligent mais c'est de
mettre à référendum en même temps ou
plusieurs référendum d'ailleurs ce qui
se fait aux états unis ou dans d'autres
pays en même temps que les élections
européennes et en même temps que les
élections intermédiaires faire une croix
dessus tout de suite et c'est vrai que
c'est bercy revoit non pas si vous
faites un référendum qui n'est pas
binaire avec un pour un compte mais que
vous pourrez plaisir qu'est ce que ce
soit un choix binaire le débat restera
du coup très national français alors
qu'on a un rare moment là aussi de
débattre sur l'europe et d'avancé ça
donc j'espère qu'on va pas qu'on
s'achemine pas vers cette solution
oui même si on peut penser que toute
façon cette campagne européenne sera
peut-être une forme de référendum pour
ou contre la politique d' emmanuel
macron on change complètement de sujets
lundi dernier c'était le 21 janvier
d'ailleurs jour où l'on commémorait la
mort de louis saez lundi